I see President Obama addressing it to
meeting they're talking about Syria
Kenya as well we've heard about and
specifically and particularly Iran
somewhat speculation that a mr. Obama
could meet with rounds mr. rouhani if
they do it would be the first meeting
between us and Iranian leaders for 36
years Hannah Thomas Peter is in New York
for us do you think that might happen
Hannah that is the big question in New
York today there has been much
speculation about whether the White
House and the Iranians will manage to
engineer some sort of encounter and will
it be a handshake will it be a meeting
in a side room will it be something more
formal it's thought that if this
encounter does go ahead it will be it
will probably be a handshake what's
known as a grip and grin for the cameras
it may you could argue just be a
symbolic gesture given the note of
caution that President Obama just
sounded all of those reservations the
that he expressed but in this great
diplomatic theater this building behind
me symbolism is extremely important and
it is worth saying that it does look
like the relationship here could really
shift between the u.s. and Iran even
though President Obama expressed his
reservations expressed all of that
caution the Iranians have been much less
guarded there was already a meeting set
up with the permanent five members of
the Security Council plus Germany and
the Iranian Foreign Minister he tweeted
earlier today that it represented a
historic opportunity president Hassan
rouhani who is due to speak to the
general assembly in just a few hours
time as said that he views this week as
an opportunity to present the true face
of Iran to the west to engage in
discussions to end this tension over
Iran's nuclear ambitions which he
insists are peaceful